please don't make this mistake if you're
making macaroni and cheese don't use
anything less than eight cheeses you
heard me right folks this eight cheese
mac and cheese was absolutely incredible
it was so cheesy extremely delicious and
it's easy to make let's get into it
comes to Pasta I always say social water
and slightly undercook it from there add
your heavy cream and your half and half
go ahead and add these spices the exact
measurements will be on the screen and
give it a mix the cheeses we have smoked
gouda cheddar
mozzarella sharp cheddar and colby jack
gonna give that a nice mix from there
you want to pour that amazing cheesy
goodness over your noodles and give it a
nice mix I know I said eight cheeses
let's get it we got extra sharp cheddar
mix it up Monterey Jack mix it up and
I've already mix it up last but not
least go ahead and cover everything in
cheddar cheese throw it in the oven
Focus was so good